[Music]
[Applause]
hey ho it's just me everybody it is H it
is just I Mark Bernard and welcome to
another episode of black man beyond
featuring just me because the other
guy's not here the other guy's off doing
uh Kev stuff um which happens every now
and again you know you may or may not
have been here long enough to know what
Kev stuff usually means um I'm not sure
if it's my Liberty to say what Kev stuff
is this time but yeah you know you could
put two and two together and and try to
figure some stuff out um so yeah it is
it is just I you're your friendly
neighborhood black man um uh we are
going to talk about some stuff today we
have uh five episodes of the Ahsoka TV
show to talk about there's been a
smattering of news um both Star Wars and
not um we got an ad we got to read
Because of course there an ad we got to
read um and uh so I'll be holding down
solo today I don't have a guest unless
you count um the Great and Powerful
mystical wonderful
B man who will bounce in uh hey there he
is hey
JayZ hello I gave myself a box this time
so I'm not like looking up at your chin
from a disembodied World below so I've
got a box everybody you deserve a box
man it's been a long time I feel like
you've earned you've earned yourself
some walls all right and I'm not
actually in scum and villainy right now
so H that's okay I am also not on a Star
Destroyer um so I feel like we are
together not what we pretend to be
unfortunate for both of us I know it
would be I mean you could do one way
easier than I could do the other
but but uh but yeah we're GNA talk about
some Star Wars stuff because you know
honestly there's nobody I'd like to talk
about Star Wars stuff um with more than
than JC um what have you been up to
these uh these past couple of weeks
my uh I had the coolest thing happen I
have to be careful how I talk about this
but um I was doing some work at the bar
before we opened and I was trying to get
out and trying to get out and I kept
having you know how projects kind of
Stack you got you want to leave you got
to somewhere to be but like one thing
leads to the next leads to the next so I
got caught at the bar which happens
often and uh uh as I was walking out
somebody said hey the guy who's sitting
at the table by
himself wants to talk to the
owner which either means one of two
things it means it's a fat man beyond
fan who's at the canteen and wants to
talk to me or it means bad news uh in
general I like okay so I take a deep
breath and I walk over and I think it's
this guy who's sitting by himself in the
booth but as I'm walking towards that
guy who looks very much like a fat man
beyond fan I get stopped by a guy who's
probably oh mid
8s and he says mid like he's 85 years
old like not dressed like he's from the
mid 80s and he goes oh are you the owner
and he has a British accent and I said
uh yeah and he has this giant
uh portfolio and he opens it up and it
is the blueprints to the original
Cantina from Star Wars and he was like I
designed the bar for Star Wars and these
are my
blueprints uh which was so crazy cool um
and he was like you know the uh let's
see these things behind the bar he's
like do you know what those are and I
was like well yes I do Mr who I'm not
quite sure is here not to get me in
trouble uh those are a rollsroyce jet
engine part he goes well do you know why
they're behind the bar I said I I don't
he said well I I walked into the Prop
Room
at whatever Studio we were shooting at
Pinewood and I saw them lying on the
floor they had a bunch of them and he
said I'm going to Chrome them and he
took one and they had him chromed and he
drew it into his um his drawings for the
Cantina which is pretty cool and uh and
uh he went if if next time you guys are
in he came he went behind the bar and
signed ours it's like the guy who is
responsible for those things hanging
there um which is pretty cool then it
turns out this
guy
it's exciting because he designed the
most famous bar in all of time right I
don't think there's a more famous bar
than the Cantina Bar from the most icely
Cantina but then he starts talking about
uh working with Charlie Chaplain and
Marlon Brando and hanging out with
Sophia
luren and this guy was telling stories
he was there on set the day that um
Brando was uh reading his lines off of
the baby's head in
Superman like how crazy he was like
telling me firsthand accounts of some of
this stuff uh it was awesome uh and it
it's it's only in Los Angeles and like
really only at scum and villain Cantina
that weird random stuff like that
happens uh where you just like this
iconic
guy that nobody's heard
and I just love the fact that like he
decided one day to roll into your bar
just like I've heard tell about a girl
that looks just like the girl that I
used to date let's see what she yeah
yeah derivative uh yeah it was uh so
that was awesome it was like the
happiest I've been I sat there and I
talked to him for like 2 hours which
everybody's always like oh my god did
you just needle him about Star Wars
I was like this
guy has worked with everybody and he has
personal stories with all of like old
Hollywood no I asked him about what was
Charlie Chaplain like I know everything
about Star Wars already what was Charlie
Chaplain like what was Brando like what
was it like being on set of Superman um
so yeah it was it was awesome it was
awesome that's amazing like did did
Charlie chap always do the little bun
dance with the spoons every time was he
an was there any question like
was he an is everybody an
so what was funny
was uh I guess he worked on the movie
that it was like chaplain wasn't like in
it chaplain was directing Brando in the
movie I can't remember the name of the
movie um I would have fail my film
history class now but uh but he was he
was saying that Brando was complaining
to him about chaplain because chaplain
wanted things very
specific and Brando is like Brando is
Brando he does Brando you know uh and it
was driving both of them crazy because
they couldn't work with each other how
awesome that's me anyway that's what
I've been up to I've I've Heard lots of
stories of Brando and the like I can't
remember what movie it is it's some like
gangster movie where he plays the big
boss and the big final like scene I
think it's Roy shider maybe it's like a
detective or or or a tough guy and he
ends up in Brando's office and it's like
this Penthouse office somewhere in like
centry City whatever and so every scene
like Brando was just like wearing a suit
having the scene and then Brando would
do stuff like he just lean back in his
chair like you know I've been thinking
about what to do with you and I remember
like I had a boss who was like yeah
because the qard are taped to the
ceiling taped to the wall and there are
the stills of like Robert Duval with Q
cards taped to his chest because that's
the only way Brando is getting through
the scene is if you're wearing the
script for him to read
it yeah it's amazing to be
that
fantastic to I suppose it's not all that
different than like the actors who wear
like the ear wigs now who have like
piece that somebody's reading them their
lines while the scene is playing out
yeah and I do remember Christopher reev
I think he was doing like Letterman like
kind of went hard on
Brando um because of that it was like
listen we all venerate him we all
understand him we all like you know genu
Fleck when he passes by but I've never
seen a lazier actor than
M we're all doing our jobs and he's
reading Q cards off of babies
yep um well that's awesome man I'm uh
I'm very very happy for you that you got
to you got to glance against greatness
and be in the presence of Hollywood
history let alone Star Wars history
that's pretty fantastic it was pretty
cool that's pretty cool um yeah I uh I I
trying to think what I've done since
last we podcasted um when I was back in
New Jersey um clearly came back to Los
Angeles had a couple of signing events
um for for a couple of books that I had
come out recently um the messenger the
legend of Muhammad Ali the the new
graphic novel that I have out from first
second uh publishing um we had a launch
part yeah there it is pretty how are you
so pretty with a launch event at a at a
small bookstore in Pasadena called
Octavius bookshelf which was lovely and
then we just had a signing at
collector's Paradise in in North
Hollywood who uh who is selling I saw
somebody in the comments mention uh hey
where can I buy some signed uh Mark
stuff collector's Paradise in uh in in
both in I think it's wikin Pasadena
North Hollywood but they what they call
a signature series where I signed a
bunch of their stock which they will
then send out um if that's that's how
you'd like to to to get your comic books
so we were signing that we were signing
the Devil's cut which is the sort of
launch book Anthology from distiller um
I've got a five-page story in there I
think there's 12 others um from people
like you know Scott Snyder and jock and
and James tinan and ROM V and tul La
lote and Becky cloan and Mar andreo and
and yeah it's a murderer row of talent
um that I'm that I'm thrilled to be
quote unquote in business with but both
of those books are on the stands if
you're if you're interested and curious
um collector Paradise will have it Jen
Salen Bob's secret stash will have it
it's kind of everywhere and anywhere um
and so it's been a lot of that it's been
back on the strike line it's been you
know still out there I think it's you
know on day 136 137 something like that
of the strike um and you know spirits
remain high uh for for lack of an
alternative like it's that's what
they're going to be I feel like um with
like
UPS winning a big big uh big win uh for
their drivers United Auto Workers are
about to go um I think since we last
talked both Marvel and Disney VX workers
have
unionized so I feel like
um the country is moving in that
direction like it or not uh summer and
if you don't like it well I think we
know where you where you were and who
you are uh but yeah I feel like we're
moving in that direction quite a bit
yeah you know and the Auto Workers I
mean the and the The Song Remains the
Same like the refrain from every labor
organization that's striking it's just
like you guys are making record profits
um the hand over fist are making money
um share some of it not even a lot of it
even just a little bit of it I mean the
United Auto Workers that the numbers
were ridiculous was like labor counts
for 5% of the operating cost of making a
car and so like even if you paid us 50%
more than we were paying before you were
not in any way eating into your profits
um as a company you're not passing that
on to the consumer at all in fact prices
have gone up 40% over the last five
years and all of that is because people
just got greedy like you're paying more
for cars than you ever had before and
they're making more money than you ever
had before and labor wasn't getting a
piece of it so to give uh to give people
an idea
um 5% of a car is labor in the
restaurant industry you are crushing it
if your labor
is is 25% or less of your profits right
so like if you're 25 to 30 that's what a
restaurant aims for typically so like a
restaurant is paying workers six five to
Sixx more as a percentage of their
profits than United than than a car
company
yeah yeah you know and so it is it is
just a matter of um as always who's
who's the heroes of the stories that you
like to watch and I bet you it's not Lex
Luthor you know I bet you it is not the
the somewhat megalan IAL head of a giant
megala Corporation um because it's hard
to make those people seem uh Noble and
or heroic because they often aren't I um
I'm going to venture into sports a
little bit but I worked uh in sports for
a long time and I worked for the major
league baseball players union uh doing
video
content um and so I got to see and now
Major League
Baseball has the best players union that
there is um basketball's gotten close
but MLB is the gold standard for labor
unions and it was interesting listening
and talking to them especially when uh
you know baseball players would talk
about going on strike because a lot of
people
um and you'll hear a lot of it about you
know oh well Rich Hollywood Elites
begging for more Millions right um and I
would hear that a lot with major league
baseball players and the thing is is
like like if George steinbruner is
paying Alex Rodriguez $30 million a year
it means that George steinbruner is
probably making $60 million a year off
of Alex Rodriguez's labor
so yes like you're like oh the
millionaire baseball players drying
their tears with million-- dooll checks
sure but like what about the multi
hundred millionaire owners who
are exploiting the labor of of the
people who are generating two to three
four times in baseball what they're
paying them you know like nobody's
asking
no baseball players asking for more
money than they are generating for the
team and and it's the same thing with
Auto Workers and it's the same thing
with with Hollywood you know it's just
you're not like you're not greedy the
people Lex Luthor is the greedy one yeah
like it's it's I think it was Tony
Gilroy on you know andor's own Tony
Gilroy who was like we are the natural
resource that they are then selling back
to the consumer and they've been strip
mining us for years and so it's time to
get paid our fair share and honestly
we're not even asking for a fair share I
don't think anybody is because a fair
share would be like hey half would be
good you know greter probably deserves
half of what Barbie grossed because
without her without that cast without
those players without that script
without the production ISM without all
of it that movie doesn't make a billion
dollars just doesn't you know so like
how do you quantify what that's worth
but it's worth more than we're getting
paid now so I understand how
inconvenient it is we all do we all
understand how much it hurts people you
know who both do this job you know as
writers and actors and then the people
who don't you know the people who are
you know in AI who are grips and
lighting texts and sound people and and
makeup and special effects vendors
everybody like everybody's hurting
because of the strike um but the strike
is not our fault like we're not the one
who we're not the ones who are still out
here um and so like and we get it you
know the audience wants the content that
it wants when it wants it and you know
right now we're in a bit of a drought
and I understand that too um but it is
it is a necessary evil um and it's not
being perpetrated by us I am I am
working on a lowbudget movie that I have
been on for like the last year so this
is a a movie that had finished shooting
last year it's not there's no scabbing
or anything going on um but there's been
a lot of back and forth with the
studio and we literally uh had to race
to get a bunch of the last stuff done
because the ENT and this is a big visual
effects house just laid off
everybody like everybody there is nobody
working at the visual effects house even
to send us a file that we may have
forgotten to
download um but if you don't do this
now then it's then every writer is going
to disappear every background actor is
going to be 3D rendered and it's not
going to work
anymore yeah I mean the the the business
needs a floor it needs a floor upon
which you can then build for the future
and all we're now fighting for for is a
slightly better a slightly better
foundation for that floor um but uh but
yeah so that's that's what I've been up
to I've been hitting strike lines when I
can I was at the Star Trek uh United
Star Trek day um I guess it was a week
ago
or so which is always fun like it's
always fun to get to see you know
previous colleagues to get to see
freaking Lavar Burton to get to you know
glance at George Decay as he's passing
by um I'm gonna hit there's a Battle
Star Galactica um picket line special
strike day next week what is today is
the 16th is the 21st at Universal so I'm
going to roll through there um it's just
so it's fun like you know it's it's a
way to to add some levity and some
lightness to what is ultimately
um the wheel of pain from con the
Barbarian you were just walking in a
circle carving grooves in in the cement
um hopefully there are there are friends
that you can walk with hopefully there
are people that you know and people that
you haven't you know gotten to meet yet
but it can be especially in the Southern
California heat um somewhat uh somewhat
deadening um both physically and
soulfully what um so when you do a
Battle Star Galactica or a Star Trek and
they promote those things if you're
Trisha heler or Katie sack off or uh
Edward James alos are
you like is it a uh like do they get
accosted by fans are they signing
autographs or is that part of it because
you're trying to get people out there
and show them what's going on and and
call attention to it or or are people
pretty chill and they let them get their
20,000 steps
um I think it's a bit of both you know
like when when I've done sort of Star
Trek day when I've done there was a big
superhero day at Warner Brothers you
know back in was that was like June
um you know it's not a rally per se like
there's no speeches you know although
Edward James almost does love to give a
speech so you can never really um hold
him uh too far from a mic um but it's
you know stopping for selfies it's
taking the pictures it's less autograph
signing because I think everybody kind
of realizes that that's not entirely the
purpose of this um but it's like all
right I'm going to walk with with the
Admiral for a couple of loops and I'm
gonna like say hello to president Roslin
for a loop or two I'm gonna like go
Lucifer's over there I'm hang out with
Lucifer and just say hello um they're
incredibly open you know super kind
because they also realize you know these
are fans these helped you know me get
where I am they helped support the show
they helped keep us on the air for
however many seasons who were on the air
like I think everybody's gracious and
shows the Gratitude and you know don't
be an is always the lesson from
one of those things like don't be the
person who's just like a little too much
and we all know what a little too much
feels like um but uh but those events
they're always kind of cool they're
always kind of chill you know and I
think everybody just loves to talk about
people who love this stuff and it turns
out that the actors who were on those
shows for four and five years love it
too you know so they they are they are
totally happy to share and spread some
of that love um so if you're in LA and
you're a nerd and you want to come to
like the Battle Star picket day it's
next Thursday from 9 to 12 at Universal
just be walking around you guys and I'm
I'm like a tangential member of the
family so I get to sit at the kids
table I always uh I always feel like
it's like a little opportunistic because
I was like man I could go and hand out
free blue milks to all the battl Star
Galactica people right down the street
from scum and villainy you very much
could like there's I've I've seen more
than one like hey Scientology is handing
out water on the line and they don't
tell you from the jump that their
Scientology but like but then they're
like hold these things have you read
dianic you have to take two bottles of
water you can't just take one um but
like there are definitely people who are
you know marketing on the line there are
definitely people who are you know I'm
not going to say passing out scripts
because nobody wants that everybody
realized that that's kind of shitty you
know there are not actors with head
shots just like littering the the pick
lines with them but there are companies
who will happily be like hey we're a VFX
vendor and we just bought water um here
you go here you go here's some ice cream
please take some of this ice cream um so
it wouldn't be the craziest thing in the
world for you to be like Mr Blue milk
guy like good humor like one of those
roll up Good Humor
things with one of these guys hanging
off of it it comes up
and absolutely you know if you had if
you had a like a rolling R2 stroller
kind of thing that you could just pop
the lid and just pull blue milks out of
it especially doing that in front of
Disney be
great be
perfect um all right so we're going to
get into some news we're going to get
into some Ahsoka but before we do any of
that we have to uh we have to give some
love we have to give some love to the
good people at our one and only sponsor
today the folks at manscape um so yes
once again manscape supports uh fat man
beyond and black man beyond so much they
provided an exclusive offer for our
listeners get 20% off plus free shipping
with the code Fatman 20 at manscape.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use the code Fatman 20
a checkout be like yourself again and
take charge of your life with manscape
now listen we have talked about
manscaped for a good long while they've
been a loyal sponsor of of this podcast
every incarnation of it um I am a I'm a
manscaped customer I'm a manscaped user
um I use it less for my balls and more
for my my big ball up here um and I use
it to trim up the beard when it gets a
little out of control um but hey if you
gota if you got to tame your your crotch
hair go for it manscape is a way to get
it done September is here and I want to
take a second to talk about self-care
when it comes to making an impression
proper grooming is essential to looking
and feeling your best when you walk into
a room that's why the sponsors of
today's show manscaped are committed to
helping men around the world walk and
talk with some Swagger this season with
the best grooming tools on the market
join the 9 million men worldwide who
trust manscaped and enjoy this offer 20%
off plus free shipping with the code
Fatman 20 at mans gate don't neglect
your beautiful self and get right this
summer with mans gate
listen for the sleekest version of
yourself manscaped has you covered from
head to toe starting with a brand new
beard HED trimmer that's the one I use
with one guard and 20 adjustable lengths
this device is the perfect device is the
perfect travel companion fit to take
care of your main wherever you are next
in line you can forget their signature
performance package 4.0 included in this
Ultimate Grooming bundle is a star of
the show The Lawnmower 4.0 equpped with
skin safe technology to minimize Nicks
and cuts in all your sensitive zones
also includes a crop preserver growing
deodorant and crop revor growing spray
powder and spray deodorant spray and
have a great day I can tell you from
experienced this has taken my confidence
in the bedroom to a whole new level
asterisk uh want something you don't
mind showing this special someone in
your life look no further than manscapes
boxers 2.0 these are without a doubt the
best boxers for men of all ages I can
confidently say I'll never go back to co
cotton boxer briefs after wearing these
so once again manscape supports f man
beyond black man beyond the entire
Beyond family so much so that they
provide an exclusive offer for the
listeners 20% off plus free shipping
with the code fat man20 manscape.com
that's 20% off with free shipping at
manscape.com and use the code fat man20
at checkout feel like yourself again and
take charge of your life with manscape
and we thank them for sponsoring this
episode I might need need to get the
beard one I've been using the the ball
one one on my head and uh it works
really well I have Jen do it and she
discovered she she has been going down
and she discovered if you shave up she's
like oh my gosh it gets so much closer
to your head um I was like yeah she's
like oh I'm going to start doing it that
way but now I wonder if I should get the
beard one and get rid of those uh
Gillette four blade things that go bad
so quickly yeah I mean I I don't know
how close the beard one will get to the
skin H um you know that's that would be
the only
caveat um but hell get it and
give it a try man it was it was it was a
Saving Grace for me during the uh the
pandemic I mean we talked about that a
while like I wasn't going to the Barbie
shop and I was not going to grow like
the Frederick Douglas afro and so I uh I
turned to my manscape gear and that kept
me nice nice and
tight um so yeah yeah man give it a go
I'm uh you could do wrong you could go
far worse arai um than given man's give
it a
go uh man do we want to BM Bunch bounce
over to Ahsoka people are screaming in
chat about it uh let's let's hit Ahsoka
let's hit Ahsoka real quick um or maybe
not real quick maybe we'll take a good
long while and and talk about Ahsoka are
you caught up I'm I'm caught up I've
seen I've seen all the way through five
um
five it seemed to have the most um worth
talking about in it I can't say that
I've been overwhelmingly Soup To Nuts
thrilled with this show I think some of
it is the pace with which it's telling
it story which is somewhat
glacial some of it is you know again we
talked about it at the jump that the the
lack of an on-ramp for people who were
not died in the wool clone wars and
Rebels
fans um some of it is just kind of
performance everybody seems to be you
know at a two when hey we could use a
six or a seven right about now um but
episode five seems to be the one where
they were like you know what even if you
hate this show there's going to be
something in it for you um and uh and
there very much was something in it for
me and I did not expect I mean listen we
all know that they filon has been doing
the kind of reclaiming the prequels has
been The Grand Design of kind of the
last 20 years of his life like I know
you hate these I think they're great and
let me show you the ways in which I
think that they're great and I think
reintroducing and re-platforming and re
contextualizing Anakin Skywalker and not
just Anakin Skywalker but Hayden
Christensen as Anakin
Skywalker um seems to be the the icing
on that particular cake and and yeah
like I get it you know like in all the
ways that I didn't get it in the
prequels you know some of which because
George directed Hayden relatively
awfully um that character was not well
written that was was not well counseled
or guided you know and not well
performed either um but watching
watching the weird kind of what if
version of Anakin Skywalker like what if
he won the fight with OB Kenobi what if
this is what Darth Vader was supposed to
be um is kind of intoxicating like
watching that stuff was like oh
okay okay we've earned it
now suddenly all of this kind of makes
sense um because when I mean and we'll
talk about the context for it and yes
spoilers we're going to spoil uh quite a
bit of of episode 5 we won't be spoiling
before episode 5 because frankly I don't
remember what happened one through four
yeah I um I did a
podcast uh for the nerd tropolis outlet
they asked me to be on and talk about
aoka and I went pretty hard I went much
harder on their podcast than I did on
this one uh for episodes one through
four which
um you know and you hit on it it's uh
the joke about the original Star Wars
Trilogy is that George's only Direction
was faster more
intense right that's that's the joke
it's it's almost like you can't say
faster more intense without hearing
Harrison Ford mocking George
Lucas um and it's like this
show
has uh looked like Star Wars but it
forgot that faster more intense is the
direction of Star
Wars like it was almost
like let's do
kirisawa but like
without without like consequence without
any energy without any
um like my biggest issue uh in episode 4
before was you know
Ahsoka is swinging her lightsaber on the
ship but right before that there Shields
are knocked out now if we've all seen
Star Wars if your Shields gets knocked
out like one more hit and we're done for
right how many times has C3PO said that
and Ahsoka and Sabian are just like well
all right I guess we're the main
characters of this show I'm going to go
out and take care of this while you fly
the ship and sabin's like you're going
to go outside and ahoka is like
yes and then it's like the most low
energy lightsaber destroying spaceships
thing I've ever
seen that was like episodes 1 through
four for me I was like what is going on
and then episode 5
happened and within 90 seconds of
episode 5 I was like this is a different
director than did the last three I could
see it in the way that the camera was
directed um and I think my guess of what
happened and I you have you you have
directed as well is that I think in Dave
felonius the show runner's head and he
directed episode one and he directed
episode 5 I almost feel
like they were trying
to they had directed Rosario
because I I've worked on movies with
Rosario and You' been around Rosario
Rosario can do anything mhm so I almost
feel as if she was directed to be
flat because in episode five they were
like you're trying to get over this
hurdle and in episode five after you
battle Anakin you're going to get over
the hurdle and you're going to be Ahsoka
again and I
think going into those episodes it's
probably a really strong idea and on the
page age it probably read really well
and then you shot four episodes of a
series where everybody's
bored and then when
she is like okay you've turned the
corner your characters turned the corner
like to me I saw Ahsoka the Ahsoka from
Rebels for the first time in episode
five I can't talk and read the chat at
the same time so I might be getting
flamed but that was the first time I saw
Ahsoka in this show um that was the
first time I saw Hara in this show you
know I still I rubbed up against the
fact that like as somebody who watched
Rebels I feel like Hara is getting poked
by Carson
Tava and she wouldn't have like
magically started hearing lightsaber
fights I think she probably would have
um I think she probably would have been
the type of person who puts Family First
and she would have been like I trust my
son he has special abilities we are
going to trust him and you are going to
trust me because I'm the
general rather than like all of a sudden
now everybody in the entire galaxy can
access the force I don't know I thought
that was a little weird uh I mean I
think everything that was not Anakin
Skywalker and and uh and the sokano was
not very good um because there's no
suspense to it right like I know they're
going to find Ahsoka it is a foregone
conclusion so why do we have to spend
four and five scenes reconnecting with
this team that's absolutely going to
find this woman because they're not not
going to so how do we add some conflict
to that and to your point there kind of
is none like if you had told me that
either like Carson and Hera were at
loggerheads and and Carson's like we got
to go like for real we're leaving I'm
not losing I'm not busting my command
I'm not getting knocked down to
you know squeegee guy and and the X-Wing
base because you got to hang out and
find you know your lost friend or I'm
not sure I believe my son is special at
all like I think he's a great kid he
claims to hear voices I have no proof of
that maybe I don't want him to be
special like Ahsoka because that leads
that says he's got a destiny that I
can't control anymore but like finding
some way to to put these these people at
at logger heads you know at at conflict
so that every time you're back on that
scene every time you're back in this
rock garden and we like if I just listen
we can find her it's like why your
scanner so shitty a b we know you're
gonna find her ahsoka's got plot on the
same way to your point she goes out with
no Shields and starts doing lightsaber
spaceship battles in four because of
course she's going to be fine you can't
kill her because it's the name of the
show um
the the thing with Anakin and Ahsoka and
I thought they did really well there's
drama there I felt like there was drama
and I don't mean melodrama I mean drama
Conflict for the first time in this show
and I I really as somebody who's watched
all of Clone Wars is somebody who saw
Ahsoka for the first time in theaters in
2008 when Anakin kept calling her Snips
and it was the the movie in the movie
theater and followed her whole character
Arc from being something where I was
like this is the worst character in Star
Wars to like this is one of the best
characters in Star Wars
um I was very very happy with what I saw
in episode 5 and really feel like the
show turned a corner um I'm excited to
see for the first time I'm excited to
see what's going to happen in episode 6
episode seven and episode 8
um
because I wasn't there for the first
part I also think that there's a world
in which you probably could have made
this episode
two I mean yeah you know I think you
probably could have taken those first
four episodes condensed them to 30
minutes done some stuff with the opening
scroll the red opening scroll there and
been into this and then spent more time
with the Ahsoka uh that we know and love
you would have gotten Anakin Skywalker
up front like it would have energized me
as like a longtime Star Wars fan much
sooner into this and saved me crapping
on the show across two podcasts in the
last three
weeks right or if you had if you had
made text the idea that Ahsoka and I'm
not even saying that this is what her
deal is um because again I remain
ignorant of most of rebel
and a good half of Clone Wars but like
if her biggest fear with taking on an
apprentice was that she has been some
way colored or tainted by the fact that
Anakin was her master right if that had
been the weight that has been hanging
over her this whole time right and so
all of the Sabine stuff gets a little
like like I don't know if I want to do
this I don't know if I can do this I
don't know if I should do this because
maybe maybe I won't be able to see
what's coming you've got you know the
forces is strong in you but you're
reckless and you're you're you're
everything that Anakin was and I am
nothing that what Obi-Wan was and if
Obi-Wan was the best of us and he still
failed how can I do that right so that
all of those first three or four
episodes are kind of about that that's
why she's so somber because
she's re-engaging with the idea that
having an apprentice being an actual
Jedi is the worst thing that can
happened to her and then this is where
you puncture that balloon with
revisiting Anakin and getting to
talk to him and getting to see and
getting to understand that there was
nothing she could have done to save him
um except for him to at some point learn
to save himself and this is the version
of Anakin who never learned to save
himself and that's the lesson that she
learns that the fight is always worth
fighting or whatever because the lesson
she learns in the world Between Worlds
is um fuzzy at best you know and I get
that that was the point like leave it
open to interpretation like you was and
audience can come to it and and pull
from it whatever you like but that idea
that I stood against Darth Vader
and I had him and I showed him Mercy
because I believe that there was still
something good in him just like his son
did you know like that yeah you you've
proved that a you you're you're worth
surviving this thing and B you've earned
the right to have a a a a um pan because
you can understand that people are worth
saving and you can see when they're
still good in somebody like all of that
then would have come to a head in the
scene and then you can push on to you
space whales like okay sure I
I'll say this uh and then lead into that
when I saw per uh Perles and space
whales in the cartoon and I saw World
Between Worlds in the cartoon in the
cartoon the world Between Worlds is put
very literally as if it's a physical
place
this I so I hated World Between Worlds
when I saw it in Rebels and I hated the
pergal when I saw them in Rebels and
this episode turned both of those around
for me because this episode made it feel
as if this is a not a physical
manifestation as much as it is
a uh connection to the force of all
things that have been and will be right
right through the force things you will
see other places the future the past
long
friends uh friends long gone right it it
goes directly back to Yoda so on that
aspect I felt like he clarified what
world Between Worlds was and it gelled
much stronger with me than it did in the
cartoon and I felt like the
purles um and I think it was just the
probably the character design they were
very cartoony and colorful in the show
and in this they felt I bought it right
like if you're going to buy the space
slug in Empire Strikes Back I feel like
you're going to buy the purles you have
to buy the Perles in this right um and
that worked really well for me my thing
with where I'm hoping they're going to
go with Ahsoka and Sabian is that Ahsoka
knows what sain's Destiny is and she
knows that her ability to use the force
is nada right she has a 12 medoran count
or whatever she's just never going to do
it and to use another Sports analogy
right there are just some people who
cannot be a professional athlete there
is a god-given gift or Force given gift
or medoran given gift that goes along
with being a professional athlete and I
think
that if Star Wars is showing that
anybody can be a Jedi or anybody can use
the force I think you're doing a
disservice I think the better lesson
here is Ahsoka is using Jedi training I
hope to show Sabin that she is better
off being who she is which is a quick
wit Mandalorian than trying to be a Jedi
Knight be and the lesson here is be who
you are not who you who other people are
telling you to be
and I think there's a real good lesson
in there that hasn't necessarily been
been explored in other Star Wars movies
that would make me as a fan much happier
than
like you know you gave us the
Mandalorian with a a lightsaber great
it's been in every fan film for the last
30 years I'm happy we saw it when it
counts but
like
make Sabine Ren's turn
that she realizes she doesn't need to be
a Jedi to be the ruler of Mandalore if
that's what it's going to
be when the movie happens in a few years
or whatever her Destiny is it doesn't
require her to hold a lightsaber and I
think that's kind of the lesson they
were trying to go at at the sequels and
didn't really get to um I think they
could do it here very powerfully uh yeah
I mean I'm I'm I'm for there being less
Force users in the world you know like
it it's it's part of the the ongoing
issue of like how many Skywalkers are
there you know like why is everybody
lousy with the force um and I'm using
lousy like you know 1920 slang which is
like everybody's got it um but I also
think you know to your point either she
doesn't have the force or she's like not
everybody has the god-given skill to be
a professional athlete but there's
always that like one person on the team
who's a little too small who's not quite
fast enough who's not quite strong
enough it's the Rudy right it's the like
here's the person with heart here's the
person who just works harder than
anybody else um now whether that person
is and could and should be a geni I
don't know but like there is a place in
this world for somebody who's got like a
touch of the gift and makes up for
everything else with just like sheer
effort and dedication um I don't
know what the best version of that is I
just I I feel like they maybe they know
what it is maybe they don't I feel like
that's
valuable um and I listen I have no stake
in space whales I will say that
I'm post Avatar 2 not a fan of people
talking to whales who then do things
that the plot requires them to do um
especially when you have a scene where
Ahsoka is holding the broken husk of
that you know the the the magic uh
laser beam key and can pretty
much tell you everything that happens
until the key opens right like like they
were there they were head it opened it
up and I think Sabine she went with him
she gave him the key he shattered it why
couldn't you also add oh yeah I see
where they went
like sure like I would not have blanched
for a second if she discovers the
of that hyperspace ring and Balin and
whatever from using the force the way
she's already using the force so in the
novels that a lot of this is pulling
from you've heard Ahsoka say air to the
Empire 14 times
already there is a thing where Luke
Skywalker can fly through hyperspace
using the force and doesn't need a
computer to plot the course he can feel
his way through it right um which is I
think what they're going to like that's
kind of how the whales can do it right
they're kind of like these beings of the
force um so yes why not why not just
lean into that that happens in the book
that you keep referencing the title to
um you know I I think that yeah take it
through there ultimately like it's kind
of irrelevant because they're riding in
the belly of the whale Jonah into their
Destiny but um you know that's a very
convenient way to separate Hera and and
uh and Ahsoka because clearly Hera and
her kid are not gonna and like why are
you putting this kid in this much danger
like is there no school for this kid to
go to I have questions
about now this is five years after
return to the Jedi I'm curious
why none of them are training at Luke's
Jedi Academy either right that's when
this is happening you know um the
uh the my you my hope do you want to
hear my prediction you always you always
take a show halfway through and you say
this is what I want to see going forward
and then it's never that good and we're
always upset and Kevin yells here is my
hope for Ahsoka give it to me as
somebody who has read again uh all the
grand Emerald
thrawn stuff from way back in the day I
do not feel like the way that they
portrayed Grand Emerald Thon in Rebels
is very strong in that in the books
thraw is almost like a combination of
like he's like Sherlock Holmes almost as
as the bad guy right he's Mori arti he
can he can see things that about you
that you don't know about yourself and
that leads him to he's a smartest guy in
the room and he can predict your
behavior based on your artwork and your
Tendencies and the things and the Nuance
that you do that he doesn't that you
don't even see yourself right and I
don't in Rebels I felt like Thon was
portrayed very much
like uh expositionally well I can I know
what people are going to do through
their artwork and then he became a
generic bad guy My Hope in this show is
that we ride the whales out to this
other
Galaxy and they find a
threat that is so terrible that it's
it's you know worse than Thanos right uh
and it for people who've read the book
something like the yzen vong are out
there and thrawn has dis discovered that
they are coming to our
galaxy and he has been waging a war out
there a a tactical War where he's
gaining
information and he is now going to come
back to our galaxy and he looks at the
new Republic and says this bureaucracy
and squabbling will never survive
against what's coming to destroy us and
enslave us and I have three years to
take over our galaxy in order to protect
it from what I know is coming and in
that way you make Grand Emerald Thon
brilliant you make him the tactician he
should be and you make him you give him
a little bit of that Thanos is right in
that his his goal is is correct but he's
incorrect in becoming a enslaving a full
people in order to avoid being
enslaved by something else and I think
you can make him very interesting and
and sympathetic but still a bad guy if
you if you build it out that
way I that's my hope that's my hope what
happens you know and I I also again I
have zero context or information about
Thon is Thon a force user or no he is
not so Grand Emerald Thon like I said he
is like the Sherlock Holmes of Imperial
Admirals uh he leads first with uh an
incredible
logic so he's he's super human in that
uh his brain is just that much better
than everybody
else's
I mean then I I think that that that
then what is kind of great is if thraw
discovers like listen I know what's
coming I know how to beat them I have
everything that I need if I can if I can
take over the new Republic and turn it
into you know wartime footing and we can
increase prod like all of the the like
behind the scenes like I'm a super
manager I know how to meet this goal
what I do not have and have no access to
is a force user you know like I need I
actually need a Jedi I need to
find somebody who can stand next to me
and be that person I need the sharp end
of the stick um and Balin is not
going to be that person for me because
he's compromised in this way you know
his panana is not gonna be that person
for me because she's not strong enough
like you're the one like you're the one
who's been like kissed by the flame of
the dark side and understands what it
means but have chosen the light side and
you're willing to do what's required
I'm going to tell you what's going to
happen unless you stand by my side and
help me and then ahsoka's got to choose
between doing the right thing with the
wrong guy and then doing the wrong thing
for the right
reasons yeah you uh you came very close
to at least the first part of that is in
the books Grand amiral
thrawn uh has pulled DNA or something
from an old School Old Republic Jedi and
has cloned him and that is his Force
user that sits
alongside him uh who ultimately goes
insane and it doesn't quite work out the
same way but yes in this case if you
have this
existential uh other Galaxy threat that
we are unprepared for and it's like the
only way we can get through this is with
my mind and your special abilities
that's super interesting right because
you're also then uh in the cartoon at
the end of Clone Wars Ahsoka walks away
from the Jedi
Order because they are pressuring her
into being something that she doesn't
believe in and
now 30 years later 25 years later you
are presenting that same choice to her
but now she's on the opposite almost on
the opposite side of it and it's it it
could be a huge very awesome character
moment of like what do you do you you
walked away from this before now you
have to and you've been flirting with
coming back but are you going to come
back and join up with that guy to to
save life right like that's what a
Jedi's true purpose is is to protect
life it's not to be a warrior as as we
just saw her fight Anakin on and to have
that come full circle it could be
amazing yeah and then to have her have
to return to this Galaxy and return to
the new Republic and return to Hera and
Sabine and whatever as you know the sort
of right hand the major Domo of
thron you know like what what does that
do to her what does that do to her
friends like does that just break
everybody's Spirit to see that well you
know one of The Last of Us what
does that do to Luke because of course
Luke is going to come back into this
because he's still alive and why
wouldn't he you know like and if you can
find way to pit Luke Skywalker
against Ahsoka Tano you know like who
doesn't want that as a season
finale um I do give me that please yeah
it's uh it could be incredible and I
know all of this is building up to the
event movie right so we're not going to
get that resolution in Ahsoka but
hopefully we get that setup and then in
Mandalorian season 4 we get a little
piece of this and then whatever else
they're going to drop between now and
whenever that Dave filon movie comes out
in 3 or four years um if the strike ever
ends um then uh I think that there are
some really cool potential between where
they took batan in Mandalorian season 3
where they could take Ahsoka and if you
can get one more and then maybe like
skeleton crew right like skeleton
Ahsoka is your Luke Skywalker bokatan is
your Han Solo and skeleton crew is your
Lando and your Chewbacca and your other
characters and if you build all of these
shows and and Grand Admiral thrawn and
this other threat is the is the thing
you know is is thraw your Loki
essentially right and you need to team
up with Loki to beat
Thanos um that could be amazing that
would be a thing that
like got Star Wars humming back in the
movie theater I think you know I mean I
I I 100% agree with you I I will say
that I'm not entirely sure that Dave
filon is the guy to do that only
because again I mean we talked about it
when Ahsoka
started you want to be able to welcome
people back to Star Wars again and if
you're building and I remember there's
some dude in in the in the comments of
my Instagram post when I was announcing
that we were going to do this black man
who was like you say that your problem
with with Ahsoka is that you didn't do
the reading um you didn't watch Force
you know you didn't watch the Clone Wars
you didn't watch Rebels that's how a lot
of us felt with the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that we didn't read 30 years
worth of comic books and I'll say you
didn't have to like they built that
Universe very specifically that you
didn't need to know anything before you
watched Iron Man before you watched Thor
you know now granted you had to keep
watching those movies like once once
there was the onboarding like once you
get past the first Avengers like you
kind of have to be in the zone to
understand what it is you could watch
Avengers I think without having seen the
other movies and you kind of understand
where you're at right like it got to
like and you there were certain movies
you could watch without any context you
could watch Ant-Man without context you
Watch Guardians without context you
could watch Black Panther without
context but I mean you could watch you
could watch Winter Soldier
without real context but like you
couldn't watch Avengers Infinity war and
then Avengers endgame and know what was
happening like you couldn't watch Black
Panther 1 and then black panther 2
expecting them to be Secrets like it did
get a little bit incestuous that way but
like if you're starting a thing if
you're if you're trying to bring people
to a new program then just a little bit
of like let's tell you who everybody is
you know let's let's open these doors a
little bit more let's just add some
context if you're already in the world
you know it and you can do it in a way
that doesn't make it like a retread but
like help a new person out just and it
doesn't require a lot and so like if
that's your giant um your giant Gambit
if that's the if that's the big work of
this version of Star Wars in the hands
of filon and John favro okay sure but
like and we're building to a movie that
you're going to Hope lots of people go
to not just the people who watch the
show you have to give us a little bit
more um handlebars that we can steer our
way through this universe um although
the only part the only part that show
that has been like that so far has been
Ahsoka meaning you could watch Mando
season 1 as an entry point and none of
it none of it and they do introduce
Ahsoka in Mando and book a Boba Fett so
it's it's this it's the
outside meaning like if Hera doesn't do
anything else for the rest of the show
and
that you'll be caught up by that movie
the the world will be caught up by that
endgame right that endgame movie so it's
only a sooka really that people are
struggling with and then and they did do
an okay job in in
Mandalorian season 2 of introducing who
batan is and and building that up right
like that wasn't people weren't really
lost in that space even though she had
been a a huge part of a couple of
seasons of Clone
Wars yeah I mean it wasn't it wasn't um
it wasn't isolating in the way that
Ahsoka is I mean the Mandalorian issue
became who's this show about you know
like we showed up for djaren we showed
up for Mando and we showed up for this
baby Yoda and then suddenly we're now
like in Season Two Season three he could
not be in these episodes and it wouldn't
make a difference um that's that's its
own separate issue three felt like the
bo Katan
uh if the Mandalorian is actually not
djaren if it's actually
a set of tales about Mandalorian and
he's handing off to Bo Katan that's what
season 3 felt like to me and even the
ending where you Circle wipe into him on
a rocking chair in retirement felt very
much like the Mandalorian is now
her right you know which hey it's all a
choice you know and it's it I'm not
going to say that it happens to every
long running show that it's some you've
got to hand off to the Next Generation
Um it happens but you know not all the
time it's just a really odd Choice here
but I do think that where when when
Marvel worked it was because they were
telling that story from Iron Man to
endgame on the movie screen you know
there were no TV shows at that point
that were required viewing and so the
audience scale was the same right like
we're all going to these things we're
all going to the ones that matter so by
the time you get to the climax we're all
here whereas if I've got to watch like
five different TV shows before you then
launch a movie is that audience big
enough to all go to that movie and make
it a hit or do you then have to try and
somehow widen that audience for the
feature in a way that like what is
happening here what's going on or do
they not care and they're like hey
Serenity and Firefly
right except Serenity was not a
hit Firefly was not a hit um I I'll push
back I think uh having
watched the episodes of Ahsoka that Dave
filon directed and the episodes of
Mandalorian that Dave filon directed I
think
that
uh I'm not going to Rave about the way
he works with the actors but nobody
Raves about the way George works with
the actors but I will say his staging
and blocking and Camera direction
is the best I have probably seen in Star
Wars the way that the camera moves in
the episodes he is directing I think is
is
uh revealing in a way that we have not
seen before for in Star
Wars I I will I will I mean not that we
need to like split hairs about this
stuff because it ultimately doesn't
matter I will say there were there were
sequences and shots in episode five that
like I would slack jaw at like holy
that's gorgeous and then there's the
stuff in episode one where we're going
to spend literally six minutes having
Ahsoka put on top of pillars and
twist things like we're in a map room
sequence that kind of goes nowhere and
kind of does nothing um I just feel and
again that was a pace issue that was
like you could have cut half of this out
and we would have gotten it like all of
these scenes feel like they could have
been edited better all of these scenes
feel like they had too much air in it
like we're we're we're patting it to get
to 42 minutes when it could have been 30
and told us the same amount of story I'm
gonna um you know people always uh yell
at you about Picard I'm gonna throw
myself in that fire I had an
interview scheduled to be an assistant
editor on
Ahsoka uh and I turned it
down
really uh it was during the pandemic I
was very busy with Hollywood Reporter
and I didn't want I had a new kid and uh
you know she was maybe a year old at the
time uh not even and I didn't want to
commute to Manhattan Beach for a massive
pay cut and in you know working 50 hours
a week plus a 2hour commute both ways
each day and I said no I said that to
somebody they're like you would have
been better had you been
there uh so like I don't think assistant
editors have that
power right but you know like that it's
it's one of those like you cannot take
back a choice you already made like and
and doing so is folly you know like we
make the choices we make we have to live
with them and you made the choices that
you made for incredibly good reasons
namely I got this kid that I got to feed
I got start building a college fund and
I can't take the pay cut to go do this
thing like that is eminently defendable
if anybody ever decides they want to
give you for it and I have no idea
how much pull an assistant editor has in
that but probably not enough to be like
hey let's take some of the fat out of
this I'll tell you what I have um been
the assistant editor on every Kevin
Smith movie since uh after Red
State and um and I have zero pull when
it comes to taking stuff out of Kevin
Smith movies zero and I promise you
Kevin listens to my opinion a lot more
than anybody at Lucas film would listen
to my opinion
so yeah um but listen all of this is to
say um I enjoyed episode five of Ahsoka
more than I've enjoyed any other episode
of this show um I still think that it
has kind of big endemic problems um you
know some of it is maybe it's an
overwhelming reverence for these
characters maybe it's a a unwillingness
to shed some plot armor from people um
maybe it's the like I know where it's
going I'm unwilling to deviate and these
episodes need to be 42 minutes or not I
don't know what those issues are but
like every now and again it engages in a
way that does sort of remind me why I
like Star Wars but all too often it is
sitting right next to a scene where I'm
like what are we doing here like why is
this happening like
um it's enough to get me to keep
watching can anybody in the chat confirm
I saw a meme that y the young lady who
played Ahsoka was the same as the young
lady who played Gamora is that true is
that actually happen the flashbacks to
when like
yeah um because she was awesome
also yeah no she's very good she's very
good and like props for Hayden
for like I don't know how old he is my
guess is he's in his mid-40s he's I
think a little bit older than me
44 yeah you know like he can still
do it man like some of that
choreography some of that like all that
action stuff and the leaping the jumping
and the twirling and all that stuff like
I mean I can't do that stuff anymore
granted I almost never could and
nobody's paying me to get into that
shape but still I just love that
um you know uh there's something about a
comeback story right and I just love
that he has the opportunity now to do
the thing that we all kind of wanted him
to to do before um and I'm not a prequel
hater at all so I don't say that like
on the
prequels um but there's some stuff in
Clone Wars where you got to see Matt
Lanter be the Anakin that you always
wanted especially towards the end and
getting to see Hayden do some of that
stuff and be that guy and um you know
the lightsaber fight was fine but like
the more interesting stuff to me was
when he was was hking at Ahsoka you know
uh during those flashback scenes um or
the force Vision scenes or whatever they
were um it was it was nice to see him
get to to do the thing and it was nice
to see as a human being it was nice to
see and as a fan it was nice to see
Anakin's face liveaction face even if it
was strangely deaged and had a weird wig
on um do that thing as well yeah I mean
it does I don't know if we talked about
on the podcast or not but and again
because I I do not come to the world of
Between Worlds knowing what it is
like I I came to it as a person who is
is somewhat familiar with this version
of the Trope of Storytelling of the
person on the brink of life and death
who is you know this is this is limbo
right this is the I have not moved on I
have not moved back
so I'm in this particularly mentally
somewhat weird world you know we've seen
it a thousand times in movies right like
the the final threshold Battle of am I
am I going to fight my way back to the
world or am I going to succumb to this
whatever so I didn't know that it's like
a force place where then if you're so
deep in the force that you can you know
see the past and the future and it's all
one and the
same but the idea of like Star Wars what
if
right like what if he won that fight
with in in Mustafar what if Darth Vader
was not an asmatic you know ampute te
what if he was what if he had everything
what if what if he finished his training
you know because I I always thought that
that was a nice mirror between Vader and
and Luke was that they both had like
abbreviated training you know that they
both were at the very least that that
you know and and I encountered this a
bit in writing the the Darth Vader um
story that I wrote for Marvel and
getting feedback from Lucas film
licensing saying things like Vader Vader
has power but not control Vader can do
big things but not small things because
I had the scene where I wanted to catch
a a laser blast in midair a bit like
kylo Ren but then like twist it and then
just send it flying back to where it
came from like Vader can't do that I'm
like Vader can block it he can Ricochet
it like we see an Empire but he he can't
snatch it from midair and like he just
doesn't have Precision he can pull a
Starship out the sky but he
can't do small things um because his
training like nobody taught him that
stuff um but to see a Darth Vader who
got to finish that cycle to see a Darth
Vader who you know maybe was able to
find a Sith Lord to finish that training
maybe Palpatine before getting
all weird and crisy electr fried was
able to do some of that stuff for him
but even just a guy who had full control
of his body again like what does that
look like what does that feel like how
much harder is it to defeat the Empire
with a Vader who can
breathe you know like show me that story
you know I remember feeling that way at
the end of of um the Obi-Wan show where
it's like this entire finale is based
upon us giving a about Luke
Skywalker when we know he's not going to
die because Canon demands that he live
so having you know having a an
Inquisitor show up on the planet you
know chasing him through this V
like end it end it before yeah just we
don't need it because there's no there's
no Jeopardy there's nothing like
everybody on this screen is going to
live except for this Inquisitor um like
Uncle Len andaru survive it Luke
survives it so why are we here um but
there is a version of that sequence
where like Luke doesn't survive we like
they kill Luke Skywalker and so
now the Galaxy's final hope is Leia that
then Obi-Wan trains himself that OB it's
Obi-Wan and Leia and not Obi-Wan and
Luke and so what happens when she's the
one who like is no longer a senator's
daughter but is a like Street
rat living if not on Tatooine but
anywhere else um and then it's like oh
I've never seen this before give me
some Star Wars where I don't know what's
going to happen yeah because I almost
always know what's going to happen um
and so like I just got this itch for
like what if Star Wars um which we'll
never get but did you watch
Visions I did I did which a little like
that it's just not main it's not the
characters you know right but you did
get there's some kind of cool what if
stuff in there yeah like it's it's it's
mostly on the periphery but it is still
like oh this is cool oh this is neat I
never thought they do with Star Wars I I
dig this um but um but yeah and so any
any way especially in Ahsoka that they
can find ways to play with our
perception of what's going to happen
that bounce against what we know to be
Cannon um that AB disabuses people of
their plot armor and makes us really
have some Jeopardy and some fear and
like oh did they just kill Hera Oh
I thought they were gonna I thought this
was G be a whole thing but no huh okay
interesting you know I want more
interesting I want more like oh
yeah but um I think I think episode five
bought me watching the rest of this
season which was hanging in the balance
the end of episode four
yeah yeah I I I mean I of course I'm
like Bound by the rules of
me that I have to watch it but um I am
walking down the rest of this path with
uh in eagerness whereas I went into
episode five with a lot
of okay how long is this episode gonna
be you know right or like a do I want to
watch this at 1:30 in the morning after
a long day of work because it I don't
care or am I going to save it until the
morning because I really want to pay
attention and now I'm going to save it
to the morning whereas before I was like
I don't
care right yeah no I I believe it um so
that's our Ahsoka Tano talk everybody um
I hope that's pretty good we went long
on Ahsoka we did like an hour sooka I
mean it helps when we both saw it yeah
um but yeah I hope we didn't uh step on
too many toes hope we didn't Crush too
many feelings um you know I I am still
cautiously optimistic but still they
they still gotta there there's a way to
there there's a way to to save this
particular ship um from being what it
was and turning to to what especially JC
believes that it can be um so hey
fingers crossed
maybe they'll listen to this podcast I
think that's the thing is like I want
everything to be awesome I want it to be
great um and let me let me pose this to
you because I get asked this a lot
especially in today's kind of culture
with any fandom Marvel or whatever um
and there's a lot of people who are just
like I came from a time when there
wasn't very much Star Wars and now that
there is so much Star Wars
um none of it's bad right and if you
think it's bad well you should have
lived through what I lived through it's
like well I did I got into Star Wars
when there was no Star Wars um and I
always likened it to like gummy bears
where
like you know this package of gummy
bears you get below the cash register at
CVS is is wonderful and it's the
greatest tasting thing you've ever had
but the three pound G bag of Gummy Bears
if you eat them all you're going to be
sick for two
days so I've kind of distilled it down
to and this isn't just for Star Wars
this is all fandoms Marvel everything is
I feel like there's two types of people
now I feel like there are and I'm
apologize to our audience but I'm going
to do use another Sports analogy which
is there are fans and there are
cheerleaders and a fan is not going to
be okay with
the New York Yankees tanking a season
because George steinbrener isn't going
to put the best players on the field I
know George Stein Brunner is dead but he
was a character in Seinfeld so whatever
like I am not okay as a fan and most
sports fans are not okay with being with
a knowing that the people in charge of
the thing they're rooting for are half
assing it right put the best product on
the field that you can but there's a
weird thing in in pop culture fandom now
where fans are criticized for not liking
a
thing that they want to Love by
cheerleaders of that thing who are like
the only thing it needs is that logo on
it right like if it if it if it has that
logo on it that's all it needs for me
right and that's like a
cheerleader right if you're a
cheerleader for the Dallas Cowboys and
the Cowboys go 0 and6 you cheer the same
way for that team that you do if they're
16 and0 and win the Super
Bowl and that's I think this thing
that's happened in fandom is like you
want the thing so bad you've become a
cheerleader for whatever it is and you
you
don't you're like a fan is allowed to to
expect the best and is allowed to
criticize the thing when it's not as
good as they
hoped yeah there's there is a this is
also going to come from a reference
slightly to the left of all of this but
it's not Sports there is a fantastic
James Baldwin quote which is I love
America more than any other country on
the face of the planet and because I do
I reserve the right to criticize her
unrelentingly you know it is that love
of being a fan that that earns you the
right of criticism you know it's like
yeah hey I was here from the beginning I
came to whatever it is I'm a fan of this
thing be better you know and I can and I
I reserve the right to be critical of it
when it's not um
I think that that Star Wars specifically
but sort of Pop Culture generally is a
Nostalgia based Enterprise and it does
require a certain amount of absence to
make the heart grow fonder and it's very
hard to be nostalgic for a thing you get
all the time so like popping the braks
is not a bad idea you know I think that
Marvel has learned that um given the
glut of Marvel content we had that all
of which was fine but none of which was
great
you know I think Star Wars has hit that
where they were like we're not doing any
more movies till we figure it out even
if the movies could have been good
better and different we're going to
we're pumping the breakes we got to slow
down these shows we gota we gota we got
to
reather we gotta Recon and figure out
ways um for us to maximize the footprint
um and so all I want is for it to be
good but I will I will shout from the
rooftops when it's like oh that wasn't
we could have that should have been
why is this not better yeah and it's not
like we're rooting for things to fail
and now I guess here's the other thing
there is enough Star Wars out there that
there's no reason that Star Wars needs
to be identity politics right meaning
like if you love Ahsoka and I think it's
mid or you love Last Jedi and I don't
talk about it anymore because of the
internet
um I think that there's enough out there
that it's okay okay it's not just 6
hours of Star Wars anymore or 6 hours of
Marvel Comics where like you have to tie
your identity to all of it like you and
I both raved about Andor I think that
would win every Emmy Award if it didn't
have a Star Wars logo on it because I
think it's the best sci-fi that we've
seen in
ages you know and so I root for all of
it I root so hard for all of it to be
great Episode by episode
yeah sometimes it's
not and it all can't be and that's also
fine um but uh but it all should want to
be it it all should try to be and it's
when it isn't and when it doesn't that I
start to get I'm not going to say
offended or upset I just get a little
sad just like H that could have been
great it all could
yeah um well we're going to we're going
to set wait to some news but we're going
to leave with some Star Wars news so
don't go anywhere just yet JC um it
seems as if you know we were all very
excited that uh that the Lando TV show
had not um vanished was not atomized it
was not uh was not
disintegrated um that uh that Donald
Glover and his brother Steven were going
to take over the the the writing and the
shooting and the directing probably it
was going to be like Atlanta 2.0 but for
Star Wars with the Lando show but now
apparently it's not going to be a show
now apparently it's going to be a
move according to to step Glover who was
uh was interviewed on a podcast he said
uh it's not even a show the idea right
now is to do a movie um right now
because of the strike it's like g a
telephone but that seems to be their
plan is and
maybe maybe this is part of the let's
not put things on Disney plus that we
cannot charge more money for and let's
go make a movie that people have to pay
to see do you think there is a little
bit of
um black panther
cultural um significance to that like
the one black dude in the Holy Trilogy
is getting his event versus Dropping It
on Disney Plus at a half hour each week
like they're going to try to capture a
little that black panther magic I mean
they very well could you know like it it
it absolutely doesn't um it doesn't seem
like an odd choice to me you know in
that for all of those reasons right like
hey it's Donald Glover who is beloved by
by a by a World At Large and I remember
somebody telling me I remember I was
having this conversation might have been
in a con somewhere and uh and this
person was like I'm pretty sure that
Donald Glover is maybe the single most
talented person of Our Generation like
because there's nothing that he can't do
right like he's an actor he's a director
he's a writer he's a musician he can rap
he can sing like I he might be able to
paint for all we know but like there
there hasn't been a single threat person
like that in a very long time um and so
I would not put it behind Disney and
Lucas film to just get behind that dude
and be like let's let's do the best
version of this we possibly can and
let's try to make it a cult cultural
event let's try to make it a pop
cultural moment um which hell it
yeah I'm all for do you know what's so I
just did some quick math do you know
what the difference in age between Billy
D when he
shot Empire Strikes Back and Donald
Glover is right now what because we're
doing a young Lando Series right Billy D
when he shot in 1980 he was 43 years old
so he would have shot the Lando Parts
when he was 41 42 right probably 41
is Donald Glover is 39 years old today
so by the time that show starts shooting
he will be around or that movie the same
age as old Lando was on Cloud City
that's
amazing yeah that's
awesome so there we go no I mean it's
I'm I'm here for Orlando movie just as I
was here for or Lando TV show I'm very
much here for the Donald Glover version
of it all which would you
prefer um I I I tend to prefer TV versus
movies only because you get more story
you know you get more chances to to kind
of twist and turn and subvert
expectations with a show but like also
six hours of Lando might be too much
Lando right like it could also just be
Oceans 11
and that might be everything you need
from a
land yeah I will say I think I tend to
like movies because I think there is
Magic
in uh a story and a ride that has a
beginning middle and end contained
within 100 100 to 125 minutes there's a
magic in the in
the
temporal way that all has to work like
you can't like for a movie to be great
there's less opportunity to fix it than
a TV
show and I think that's cool
however I would love to
see an
episodic let me tell you about the time
Lando show and it's just every episode
starts with let me tell you about the
time uh I think that would be incredible
yeah I mean I just after having finished
um Atlanta not too long ago I came to it
very late um you know they may or may
not have tried to take my blur card um
for not watching Atlanta when the rest
of the world was um but that's fine we
do things in our own good time but like
I'm I'm of the belief that that I'm not
gonna say he can do no wrong because
there's episodes of that show I didn't
love but in general like yeah no like
wicked talented that dude is so like
whatever version he thinks is best I
will take
but Lando is not a character I need more
character of I just need to have a good
time with Lando and I feel like it's
either the like we're doing six episodes
and six Adventures about the time Lando
did this cool or the here's how I
stole Cloud City and this is just the
two-hour version of my spectacular Heist
from which I stole cloud city under the
under from out from under the dude who
had it before I
did yeah Ben bamboo says I wanted a
Billy D Williams narrated flashback show
for Lando that's I mean that's my that
is my Al like Billy D's
886 get him just get him yeah you know
and also let us never forget that Billy
D Williams given name is William
December Williams you guys maybe the
best name ever given Al
William Williams yes sir I'm right
here um couple of the quick news hits um
have you been watching um one
piece I have heard amazing things about
it though um I never watched a stitch of
the anime of which there are apparently
about a thousand episodes of um so I I
much like clone Warson Rebels I came to
it somewhat cold um but I'm kind of in
love with it like the liveaction version
of it like it's it is incredibly
good-natured it's got a ton of humor and
empathy it's got a main character who
like his superow is not just that he's
kind of made of rubber is that he
believes in himself to an almost sickly
degree which is also someone magnetic
you know somewhat magnetic and so it's
just fun like it's kind of Daffy and
silly
um they did spare no expense with making
it but because looking at that show it's
like what and apparently they they shot
it in South Africa and used a bunch of
the pirate ships that were left over
from black sales that were still
there wow and just like repurposed them
and refashion them into into you know
these kind of fantastic
things but like and it's and it's an
interesting test case you know using
that watching that and then watching the
silk at the same time both pieces of of
media both TV shows based on something
with hundreds if not thousands of
episodes of story behind it already but
the onramp to one piece is much simpler
and much more effective and emotional
and clear than the onramp to Ahsoka was
but also looking at it in terms of like
liveaction adaptations of anime and why
this seems to be succeeding where cowboy
bbop seems to have failed um in that it
it given it has had so much to adapt
from it just takes What It Wants
refashions What It needs to remembers
why you're showing up and it's not out
to make sort of frame by frame
replications of the source material but
it's just kind of getting the spirit of
why you loved it and then not to say
making a new thing but just adapting it
where I always feel as if when you don't
do that you do somewhat at your own
Peril
like you know Cowboy bbop felt a little
inert because it always felt like it was
just we're doing the thing that you saw
in the cartoon and you'll love it
because it was in the cartoon as opposed
to we're making a new thing inspired by
the cartoon and we'll take what we want
and we'll leave the rest um and there's
just an energy to it that is not um that
that didn't that didn't make its way
into Cowboy bbot the uh the big hole in
my nerd fandom is anime
that's my like uh you
know exhaust port on my nerd death stars
I just have
zero basis on any of it so maybe I'll
maybe I'll jump in with this yeah I mean
it goes down real easy the cast is so
just
engaging sorry yeah they're not cartoons
Mark says cat food no you're right um
it's anime um I similarly have a have a
kind of a giant blind spot for most
modern anime like I I was a bit of an
anime movie kid because like you know
when I came of age was that first like
80s wave of imports of like Fist of the
North Star and Aira and Ghost in the
Shell and and that sort of stuff like
ninja scroll like I kind of inhaled
because there was so little of it but I
I am not up to date at all like with the
the flood tide of anime that seems to
come via Netflix or Hulu or or crunchy
roll or whatever like there's so much of
it there's too much of it and I just
can't get down with it um but uh but
this is cool and it got picked up for a
second season because apparently it
seems to be doing so well on Netflix
that uh that they were like sort of two
weeks out like you know we're going to
do more of this um and we are not in any
way hungry for uh for Source material so
so yeah if you loved if you love The
Adventures of the straw hat pirate
then uh then you're going to get another
season of them um there is no set date
on when because clearly there's there's
no writing and a second season until
we're done with the strike um but
Netflix seems to be intent on doing
another season so huzzah everybody wins
um and finally I guess it's a weird bit
of the comic book news that came across
the the the the transom the other day
and I'm not entirely sure how to parse
it because I am no expert in sort of
copyright trademark law but Bill
Willingham um the Creator the writer
creator of fables for for DC Comics in
Vertigo um has declared that it is now
uh public domain and that because of a
sort of long-standing feud between him
and DC Comics over a sequel and whatever
and so he gotten so frustrated and tried
to sue to get the rights back and that
was never going to happen and so he just
said you know what it belongs to
everybody now I don't think it does I
mean I think that DC has the trademark
on some of that stuff which actually
supersedes copyright and so you cannot
use those fixed forms of those
characters you cannot use the title
fables you cannot use most of the things
that makes that uh that comic book
series
unique but fables was based on you know
Snow White and The Big Bad Wolf and
Pinocchio and you know all these
characters taken from sort of Grim's
fairy tales and popular culture all of
which are already in the public domain
so like Once Upon a Time on ABC was
basically
fables um but because all those
characters belong to the world they
could do that without an issue so like
if you wanted to make a story about the
big bad wolf you could do that even if
you wanted to put them in modern times
you could do that you just couldn't do
any of the stuff that was in fables and
call it fa
um so so yeah it's a weird sort of thing
which seems to be born of some animus
between a Creator and DC Comics which if
you know the the The Saga of Alan Moore
is not a new thing um Alan Moore who
also most recently decided that all of
the the residuals and proceeds that he
would get from the sale of um V for
Vendetta and Watchmen and you know uh
and and League of exter gentlemen
everything that he did for DC Comics all
of that money is to go directly to Black
lives matter um because he's like I
don't want your money I don't give a
I've hated everything done from it
I'm sort of washing my hands from it but
making sure that the proceeds of it go
to a place that uh that he feels can do
some good and I wholeheartedly agree
with both that decision and his choice
of where it goes but DC and uh and comic
Creator relations does not seem to be um
in the best of place what's interesting
is um the film version the film music
version of fables is Michael Bay have
you ever heard this the Michael Bay
trick so when Michael
Bay not always but a lot of times when
Michael Bay will want to put a song in
his movie and it's too expensive so
um he will
hire a he will pick a song from so like
kiss right kiss has a ton of huge hits
that they didn't write like God gave
rock and roll to you right it's not a
kiss song but if Michael Bay wanted to
use that song in a movie he would hire a
Kiss cover band and pick a kiss song
that kiss didn't write so that he is
paying royalties on the original band
and not the he doesn't have to pay Jean
Simmons any
so that's the trick in movies when
you're when you hear a song like in um
the one that I always think about
because I I know the guy who sang it is
um in the movie rockar with Mark
Wahlberg and uh and Jennifer Anderson
which is essentially the Judas Priest
story they use the song California Girls
by Van Halen except they pay the music
rights for the Beach Boys which is much
cheaper than Van Halen and then got a
Van Halen the best Van Halen cover band
which was called Atomic punks to
re-record the song as Van Halen and so
he's paying Pennies on the dollar for
the music he's using in those situations
so it's kind of like this guy being like
hey if you want to tell a story with the
big bad wolf in Pinocchio go for it
like I guess I could have done that
before I got your permission there's a
there's also a great trick that um Edgar
Wright did in baby driver which
is there are rather than
like rather than use like the Dr Dre
song like the next episode or whatever
um in the in the in his movie he would
then use the song that that sampled and
then use the
original like he uses the Dave mallum
The Edge which has like that saying
like like that part of it was pulled
from this original song he just uses the
original song so it both gets you
immediately in the head space of the
more famous version of it for like a
fraction of the
money oh that's smart yeah like it just
conjures that that song he does that
like three or four different times of
like here's the thing that you think it
is but it isn't that but I got you there
for far less money um which I thought
was just brilliant like all I need to do
is get you in the head space and you're
here um but yes that's all of which is
not quite as Insidious as the Jee
rotenberry I'm writing lyrics to The
Star Trek theme song um so that I know
get half of the publishing from
Alexander courage um which is like of of
Dick moves that is a Hall of Fame like
silver medal dick move like how much do
you think you know kept on going into
Jean's pocket because he wrote lyrics to
a song that you've never heard the
lyrics to um but always got paid for
every time it appeared on the air yeah
yeah um but yeah like it it it remains a
uh a slow Newsweek slow news months slow
new season
um and so until until the strikes are
over and you know like every week there
is a reason to have some hope like it
seems as if the wga and the the studios
are going to sit down sometime in the
near future and have another series of
conversations hopefully they will lead
somewhere um because the strike will end
it has to end um you know they all of
these billion dollar companies the only
thing that they sell are television
shows and movies
and so that is the only product that
they make so they will have to make that
product and so otherwise Universal goes
out of business and Disney goes out of
business and warblers goes out of
business and Paramount goes out of
business because all that they have is
either the library which they cannot you
know make as much money on as new stuff
um so they need the new stuff so it'll
it'll it'll be resolved sooner rather
than later is my hope but it will
definitely happen
um but until then we are somewhat
trapped in a somewhat news drought but
hey we'll muddle through as we always do
um but I guess that's it for News man um
do we feel like we should go to to do
some Q&A anybody have some questions and
we can do some Qui quick uh quick QA
I've got I pulled I've got three from
the uh from the stream uh AI Pacino
wanted to know uh if you had to open a
bar based on a movie or piece of Pop
Culture what would it be based on I have
my
answer fancy that um I always
thought that like let's say I had a
couple billion dollars lying around and
I'm very surprised that this never
happened but like and maybe Atlantic
City was a place for it maybe Vegas
there's still room for it but why there
was never a James Bond licensed
Casino like why there was just literally
never a Casino Royale right that like
you know and not that you'd want it to
be quite as immersive as like the the
Star Wars hotel which you are finally
going to right I am I leave a week from
tomorrow oh I cannot wait that is a
reason to come back and do a podcast we
could do one we could do one I get back
on the 29th we could do one the last day
of the
month excellent um that'd be amazing but
like and so not that you'd want your
James Bond casino to be quite that
immersive but like in the way that
Playboy had casinos and stuff like just
the vibe and the feel and the the ethos
of like high luxury and good taste and
excellent food and and and expertly made
drinks and like gambling and
entertainment like all that felt very
James bondy um and the fact that there
never was one is somewhat odd to me um
not that I liked this movie very much
but there's probably definitely a Dick
Tracy bar to be made um like very
colorful very sort of mobster very like
you know Jazz Age turn like the The
Roaring 20s but also with
primary colors and all of that
um I have I have two you have two
okay two other bars that I I will never
do I have I have ones that I want to do
that I'm not going to say out loud but I
have two that I think would be amazing
on your dick Trace James
Bond the
no-brainer is the ink and paint Club
from
Roger where you get it's just like real
old school and you have some Holograms
playing pianos of like Donald and Daffy
Duck and you do that no-brainer coolest
place to hang out ice cubes that are
dyed black so they look like actual
rocks like the whole thing somebody take
that and run with it somebody who's
going to mess me me about how to open a
scum and villain do that instead it
doesn't exist
um the other one that I think would be
amazing is with how
accessible projection and uh
like uh LCD screens are now a Hol Deck
bar a Straight Up Hol Deck bar um and
what we did at scum and villain is we
redid our front
um front room is a
very
uh
24th century inspired
spaceship um and we have we haven't put
it up yet but we're going to put a sign
over the front door to when you walk
into like this part of the bar that just
says holc 3
active nice so for everybody who comes
in claiming to tell tell me what what my
bar is or is not is actually just a Hol
deex
simulation it's like my little troll uh
but I think you could do this the floor
the walls and the ceiling and even the
bar top and front as screens and so it
could change every you know you could be
in a forest and then you could be in a
spaceship then you could be in a on a
desert plant plan and you could do all
sorts of really cool stuff with
that that's kind of awesome yeah I
remember being in New York um I guess
this would have been like the the the
mid to late 90s which seems to have been
the Heyday for
like vaguely popcultured inspired bars
um so I remember there was a slaughtered
lamb which is right out of American
Werewolf in London I remember the Jackel
and hide sort of restaurant bar which
was very like Explorers Club like it was
just like here's a canoe on the ceiling
and here's like this shrunken head and
this skeleton and this Mars
2112 yeah you know like what if you went
to Mars and also the future but never
went to either and the food was really
shitty it was a bit of that um so I
remember like the slaughtered L was the
most successful of them because it was
just a pub that also had like a couple
of werewolf heads on the wall but it was
like just enough to kind of get you into
that Vibe um but and I always kind of I
don't even know know who the would
go to this but I always love the
technoir bar out of Terminator which is
basically just like you know it's a
80s bar that just plays sort of
80s music but so Jen um at the space
that is scum and villainy now she had
designed the previous incarnation of
that bar which was um kind of a rock and
roll bar it was called loaded and half
of the bar they they expanded it and
they were going to do a
barade and they they were like what uh
which I can't say Barcade because it's
trademarked going back to that so they
were going to do a uh arcade bar and um
and they the people who owned it asked
Jen to pitch an idea and she was going
to call it uh neon Noir and it was going
to be that club full of arcade
machines that's pretty sweet didn't
happen
that's pretty sweet yeah I mean I feel
like there's there's a there's a good
Litany of Pop Culture bars that
would actually be pretty great I mean
hell there's a whole mess of them in the
chat um you know the Roadhouse Bar um
the Continental you know Hotel bar the
titty twister from from dust Dawn
frany um from Lord of the Rings um all
of that stuff would be cool I mean how
Marin's bar from Raiders like the in
Tibet would be pretty
sweet um basic could do that in La
though or in California you can't have
wood burning a new wood burning
fireplace here so it would really yeah
you can't if you're you cannot build a
house with a B wood burning fireplace
anymore you have to have a house that
has one in order to use it o you have to
the gas right yeah and I guess you could
set the curtains on fire like if
somebody ordered the right drink you
know the uh um you know the the tote
drink or something like that the
curtains could catch on fire
nice I'm sure you can
that um next question Reed
Erikson uh what Nerd movie quote do you
live by I have mine I've cheated though
because I've had these questions up on
my monitor for the last
hour um I think
I mean I've I've used this probably more
in the
last five years than I've ever used it
um no maybe more like six years um but
uh but it's always a standby it's always
a
favorite but it's the
like take off and nuke the side from
orbit it's the only way to be sure
um and you know the site being
everything from a specific place to like
the World At Large um it has been a
somewhat dispiriting uh you know half
decade of late but yeah no that one from
Aliens always always finds a way into uh
into into my dialogue slash every day I
um uh I am a little more optimistic than
that uh my quote since 1999 has always
been uh Quon Jin quote which is your
focus determines your
reality and I always took that to mean
if if
you uh believe it and you work hard
enough you can you can do the
thing um and it's served me well in my
life and uh so that's the advice I
always give everybody is your focus
determines your
reality not
bad not bad and uh last one because I'm
getting hollered at on my phone
um uh where are you you said this was
gonna be a short one yeah uh geek
renderer uh wondering what film you
believe is the most perfectly made movie
of all
time
H
um sadly this answer answer will also be
the same as my last answer which is
aliens like I think aliens is perfect I
think aliens achieves everything it sets
out to achieve I think the the character
story is incredibly rich and dense and
simple and emotionally resonant and
understandable I think the action is
just phenomenally well executed I think
the the special effects remain fantastic
like they really really really hold up
even though I mean granted there's like
one rear projection shot that's a little
bit dodgy um but given that they made
that movie for next to nothing um you
know $6 million I think was the budget
in that movie and and none of it feels
shitty it is the
Prototype you know for almost every like
I mean granted the dirty doesn't kind of
did it before here you know it's a war
movie and so the war movie about the
soldiers who show up think they know
everything who kind of begin to die one
by one by one leaving just like the Lone
Survivor I mean you know Predator would
do it a couple years later um but it's
it's also a horror movie cliche of like
Ripley is the final girl and like
everybody else who thought they knew
everything fell by the wayside even like
the Ally that she trusted who knew his
to the duplicitous you know
business guy to the kind of bragger you
know jocks like all of it but um like
and yes Jose monster there is a woman
named Janette Goldstein who's playing
Vasquez
yes but I do I do grade on a temporal
curve in that while that was never great
there is a long history of Hollywood of
white people playing brown people um and
Hollywood was never incentivized for
that not to happen as recently as like I
don't know 200 5 2006 you know when
Angelina Jolie is playing like a Chilean
woman like yeah all right sure I guess
um but no I think I think aliens is I
think it's it's James Cameron's best
movie um I think it might be the best
action movie ever made um and I think I
think it is perfect um as always your
mileage may vary but uh but I've seen
that movie like 70 times um
conservatively speaking and uh and have
yet to find a bug that isn't also a
feature I um I have two I have the the
one that everybody always says and then
I have another one the one that
everybody always says is Die Hard uh
there is not a wasted frame in Die Hard
uh there is nothing in that movie that
doesn't uh subtly set something up that
pays off huge l
um but my other one is the Karate
Kid if you go back and you watch Karate
Kid similarly to Die Hard there is not a
wasted scene in that movie and the
example I always give is um the opening
of that movie is very long the opening
title sequence and it starts in New
Jersey and you follow this shitty
station wagon all the way to R
and what you don't realize that you're
looking at that entire
time is
uh is
uh the shitty bicycle strapped to the
roof and that shitty bicycle is a thing
that that
defines he is all the cool kids have
um uh motorbikes he has a pedal bike the
pedal bike is the thing that introduces
him to Mr Miyagi who becomes his best
friend who who
also uh teaches him and helps him grow
and is his Avenue to his whole new new
life uh that is how that movie starts
and everything in that movie is
intentional and purposeful in the same
way D die hard is uh so Karate Kid I
will say is my perfect movie go back and
rewatch it you will be surprised at
how fantastic it is I'll also say like
honorable mention which is silly and
it's cliche but we don't get them
anymore is pretty woman go back and
watch Pretty Woman it is
phenomenal in the fact that it just does
what it's trying to do expertly and we
don't get any good romantic comedies
anymore that aren't just
comedians uh improvising for hours on
set that gets cut down by an editor into
something that resembles a movie go back
and watch Pretty Woman that movie is
fantastic as well yeah I mean and I
think that like yes there's a bias for
like the 80s and 90s for us because
that's when we grew up um and also they
made a lot of different kinds of movies
in the 80s and 90s that they would kind
of stop making later on um and so like
yeah romantic comedies existed you know
just straight up theatrical
comedies existed um you know like mob
movies existed and cowboy movies existed
like all of these various genes you
could go see in a theater that can't do
that anymore um but also I think that
there was a rigor to movies in the in
the 80s and 90s like I will I will stand
by like midnight run as just and again
we are
not as Kevin likes to say shining a
light to cast aspersions anything else
like what do I think is the most perfect
movie it is mine and it's aliens and I
get it there are scores of other great
movies out there you know that if a
person was like you know what I think
it's great LA Confidential I
could not poke a hold in that movie
either um you know I couldn't poke a
hole in Raiders you know well I haven't
did but still I love it um you know I
can't I can't really poke a hole in like
Beverly Hills Cop I really can't poke a
hole in um When Harry Met Sally I cannot
poke a hole in Ghostbusters like
all of those movies are great and
phenomenal and the ones that we love
like if you went back and watched like
the movies that made us to see how
fraught those movies were and how much
trauma they went through to get to the
place where we love them and how so
easily it might have been a different
movie a worse
movie you know that but for the grace of
handful of people who believed in it or
a handful of people who hated it in the
process and like nudged it and and or
hey the casting for this was almost
incredibly different but we just locked
into you know will frell nobody wanted
will faral for like elf you know they
wanted Eddie Murphy to be in
Ghostbusters and not Ernie Hudson like
Beverly Hills Cop was supposed to be a
stone movie like all of these things
were like this close to being something
different um yeah
was St movie totally like Cameron almost
got fired from Aliens like four
different times because it was almost a
crew Revolt because they hated him like
all of these things are almost on the
verge of never existing but they do and
you know we sort of love it for that um
but yeah that was just my favorite
that's the one that comes to mind that's
the one that always comes to mind but
yeah Hollywood is littered with almost
failures that turned out to be Classics
um you know and similarly like Pretty
Woman Like if you read the the
the versions of pretty woman that almost
were the like super grim and gritty like
prostitution drama that it almost was um
that the first script is written as that
you know the right people came involved
and changed it into the thing that we
kind of know and love but
damn but good choices
everybody all right good that's it I
have to go get my crying daughter out of
the bathroom all right you get your
crying daughter out of the bathroom um
that has been black man beond with this
week I don't know when we're coming back
it might be when JC comes back from the
the Star Wars Hotel it might be sooner
we might get Kevin um we may not it
might not who knows but hey until then
until then um thank you for tuning in
thanks for hanging out on a Saturday
night slash evening slash I don't know
where you are so whatever time it is
there melt um happy High holidays uh
everybody be good and I will see you
next time uh so yeah for black man
beyond this week I'm Mark Berard and
that's JC renberg um tune in next time
same black Time same black channel uh
smodcast.com or youtube.com/ Kevin Smith
uh peace love and soul y'all till next
time this is the C greetings everybody
and welcome to the AKA ask keev anything
every Saga has a 10year anniversary
ladies and gentlemen and this is what
happens with Jay and S Bob get old up
Kevin Smith
ch